was raised Catholic and I think where I
was I'm not going to speak for the whole
Catholic faith but we're from how I grew
up it was literally just a list of rules
that you just you just need to follow it
because this is what the word says and
in some ways that's true but it wasn't
until I stepped away from the faith for
a short period of time until I actually
had the context of why those rules are
in place God made you he knows you more
than you know yourself he knows every
hair on your head so he's just don't use
them as as God being evil and wanting to
oppress you because he made you he it's
view it as more like he made you and he
knows how you can find fulfillment and
happiness and freedom and avoid more
pain than there already is in life